all right this afternoon it's been very
warm but then the wind started kicking
up and nate is in tonight for ted with
more details on the forecast nate you're
exactly right about that denise in fact
you can see it very much from our camera
on top of the red rock resort way out on
the west side of town looking to the
east palm tree whipping in the wind if
there's some good news with the wind
it's kind of gotten rid of some of the
haze
but if the winds stay over 30 miles an
hour we'll get some blowing dust and
sand
let's talk to check out four
neighborhoods for you win from the west
in las vegas at 109
everybody else from the southwest
blowing to the northeast henderson 108
111 in north las vegas 110 at the air
force base
with gusts around 25 30 miles an hour
we'll check a couple of other
neighborhoods here in a second
i wanted to make sure you know about the
excessive heat warning
it is set to expire at 8 o'clock this
evening for southern nevada
southern clark county southern nye
county parts of southeast california
now the excessive heat warning for
northwest arizona that's going to last
until tomorrow night
so some other neighborhood temperatures
how about 111's we've got a bunch of
them from aliante there's the air force
base downtown the strip
green valley 109 for seven hills and
anthem mountains edge you're at 107
up to 109 for centennial hills you want
some relief you head up to kyle canyon
where it is 82.
we wanted to check out nevada and beyond
as you might guess
the hottest temperature is going to be
death valley 122.
laflin's not too far behind at 115 106
in sandy valley over the hub in prop
107.
you got to go way up in northern nevada
for double digits in caliente you're
close to the triple digit market 99 same
with tonopah
good evening to cedar city with the 93
kingman hanging on at 104.
all of these gusty winds will continue
through tonight and be back
again tomorrow the official high for
today 112.
just short of the record high of 113
there's the normal high for this time of
year
at 104. low this morning a very warm 89
we think it will be a little bit cooler
when you get your friday started all of
this breezy windy condition is going to
slowly push out this area of high
pressure
which has caused all of that excessive
heat
now we check in on your family and
friends across the nation some showers
over the mid-atlantic states are
pushing out into the atlantic gulf coast
rain it is staying in
over the open waters had some strong
storms through the midwest parts of
minnesota iowa
wisconsin and illinois but no really
tremendously severe weather so for
tonight here in las vegas
we think you'll start your friday
morning with an 84. again those breezes
may be still 10
20 miles an hour then the eight day
forecast has us
at 106 again for the high 106 also for
saturday maybe getting a little bit of a
break from the heat even more 104
for monday possibly 103 on tuesday
really not a bad way to start that back
to school forecast on monday kirsten
yeah that's not too bad at all thanks
nate